ما بين المجال الطبي وعالم الموسيقى
مسافات ناعم ناغمه بينها الطبيب الفنان
عمر الامين الامين الذي يعزف على عده الات
موسيقيه لعل ابرزها الكتاب
ويلحن معظم اغانيه التي تتركز ما بين
الرومانسيه
الحزينه
الاغاني السودانيه القديمه التي تحمل
معاني عميقه وتقديمها وتطويرها بشكل عصري
لتعريف الجيل الجديد بها لعل اخرها اغنيه
انا السوداني انا الفنان الراحل حسن خليفه
التي قدمها بلحن وتوزيع جديد
[موسيقى]
احنا في المقدمه قبل شوي قلنا اغاني حزينه
لكن هذا الفنان لديه ابتسامه جميله ودائما
مبتسمه ان شاء الله يا اهلا وسهلا صباح
الخير خليني اسهل هل بيعني اليوم الحزن
يولد لربما اغاني تشعرك
بالسعاده هي ربما هروب من واقع حال ام انه
احنا نطرب على الحزن والذكريات الحزينه
سناب احس انه هي في النهايه مشاعر اذا
كانت حزينه او سعيده
انك تحس الاحساس بالحزن او بالسعاده في
الحالتين انت بتكون في نشوه كده من
المشاعر يعني تجمع المشاعر هو الاحساس
حاجات داخليه وتطلع بحاجه
كتير لفتني بانه اول شيء انك طبيب وموسيقي
في نفس الوقت وتاخذ اغاني القديمه اللي
موجوده منذ اجيال وتقلبها بقالب جديد
بتقربها من الجيل الحالي اول شيء بدنا
نسمع شي حتى ناخذ نموذج وبنفس الوقت كيف
بتعمل هيك كيف قدرت
بصراحه هو هو حب للغناء القديم
مليان كلمات عميقه جدا والحان جميله بس
بتلاحظ دائما الجديده بتحاول انه هي ما
بتستسيغ ما بتحس انه في في بين الغناء
القديم والشباب هي كانت صدفه يعني وجود
الجيتار كعلى ممكن تكون محايده تجدد
الميوزك السودانيه القديمه بشكل انه نحن
ما نغير في الاساس بتاعها وتوصل يعني
توزيع جديد بالضبط كده طيب خلينا خلينا
نسمع وخلينا نحكم لانه في جايك سؤال
بس هم يهاجمونك يعني أنا
في الموضوع ده
من الاغاني القديمه من اغاني التراثيه
كانت بتقول
انا
اتمنى كل زماني زماني فاتن كنت كنت بتمنى
ليله
وقاعده
الحين
والله يا درتي يا الغاليه والله
ليله ليك الخلف
والسنه والله
الاهاليك الخلق
قالوا غير مي
تين مبلغ جنه والله يا درتي يا الغاليه
قلبك طال سهريه اذا سواد حظيها نجاره عليك
والله
الغالي
[موسيقى]
عصرتيني اكيد شنو اوكي ما في مشكله يعني
مثلا
الطريقه القديمه
[موسيقى]
ده حبيبنا
مالو سافر روح
مغشانا
احيل الخوه
[موسيقى]
والتغيير هو التغيير ما بمسك القالب
الاساسي بتاع الاغنيه فضيح للكلمات الاله
في حد ذاتها يمكن تكون جديده على الجيل
انا حبيت النموذج
القديم وفيها اشي
احب القديم
وين داخل
[موسيقى]
ايوه انا درست جامعه الرباط في الخرطوم
تخرجت من كليه الطب واعمل حاليا في نفس
المجال بس الموسيقى ساعدتني كثير
في الضغط تاع القرايه يعني
هذا كان موضوعنا يوم امس لكن اليوم انت
سوداني خلينا نسمع انا سوداني ههه
ايوه هذه الاهلي يا سلام والله نحن تحيه
من هنا بنحيي كل الشعب السوداني ونقول لهم
ان شاء الله يعني السودان حيرجع جميل
حيرجع سعيد ترجع الابتسامه في في في وجوه
كل الناس الامل موجود اللهم امين هي
الاغنيه كانت تعبير عن عن حاله المغتربين
لنا وطن اذ نباهي به ونفته
[موسيقى]
نتغنى بحسنه ابدا دونه لا يروقنا
حزن
نتغنى بحسنه ابدا دونه لا يروق
نا
خير هذه الدماء نبذلها
كالفدائي حين يمتح
بسخاء بجراه بق
وه لا يئن جهدها ولا تين
وا
تستهين الخطب عن جلد تلك تنهال وهي تتزن
انا سوداني
سوداني انا
يا سلام الله والنعم والنعم وان شاء الله
دائما السودان يعني يعود الى يعني اجمل
مما كان باذن الله تنتهي هذه الاوضاع لكن
دائما انتم لكم دور بايصال رسائله الى
الداخل السوداني ربما هناك من كل ما يحدث
من هذه الفوضى هناك ثمه حياه
يعانون في الداخل وفي الخارج
سوداني شكرا عمر الامين فرصه سعيده جدا
شكرا يا دكتور الله يخليك شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات